was no surprise that people started  developing attractions  relationships caring for for the people  that they work with because they spend  so much quality time with those people  and it's it's not just quality time it's  like happy quality time it's Quality  quality time because when you're at home  with your spouse sorry and you have kids  there are issues there are fights that  are coming up but when you're with that  person and you're just like oh I'm happy  like I can just be here I can be me so  you feel like you I feel like it is more  cheating than even having sex with  somebody because you're giving so much  of like that good side of you that the  person at home doesn't get right